[Music]
my name's tyrone i completed my house
sale yesterday okay first thing
i love the music digging the music and
second thing i love the fact that you
just put yourself out there right away
respect from me and this is a hmo i've
just purchased
come and take a look
[Music]
so inside to the right we have our first
bedroom
that's not any bedroom that's a bedroom
that used to be a sitting room people
say i've got a sitting room what am i
gonna do with it
maybe i need to get a builder out to
turn it into a bedroom no you don't you
just need to put a
bed in it that's what this guy's done
tyrone put a bed
in a sitting room put number one on the
door
now it's bedroom number one love that if
we just if we just go upstairs
this is our second bedroom
our third bedroom to your right
and finally our fourth bedroom
also to the left we have a bathroom just
here a second bathroom just here
and i'll show you downstairs so four
bedrooms two bathrooms hmo
fantastic just like my very first
property and the cool thing is
is to get a four bed hmo you don't need
a license
there's no license there's no planning
there's no regulations like that
so it's pretty straightforward it looks
like the doors of fire doors i think i
hope
which just keeps the place safe and uh
it's his first property investment so to
get your very first property investment
as a hmo
that that's that's pretty impressive
it's much much much more profitable than
a single
i hope you give the figures our living
room
this is the living room and just joined
to the
the kitchen which obviously all the
students can use
yeah this is the garden i'm in this
video so
i just want to show people that it is
possible that you can get what you want
as long as you work for it
because i've had a lot of people
doubting me over a very long time that
you won't get it you're you need to stop
and just trying to put you off is just
ignore that and just do what you got to
do love love
love this guy's attitude that's exactly
right you are going to have people
naysayers saying you can't do it
i mean this guy probably looks about my
age maybe around about 28 29 years old
and for sure people probably advised him
you know buy a house to live in first or
rent or don't buy
and do property because there's this
risk and that risk and the media is
saying this
and he's got through that and pushed
through that so no doubt this is going
to be the first of many
and also in a few years time i want to
look back to the stage i'm at now and
see how far i've come
and built as a person okay so that's
great specifically what is it you've
accomplished so far
today of this is this is a four bedroom
hmo behind me as you can see
um i've bought it i've purchased it um i
don't owe any money on it as it stands
it's it's completely debt-free and um
yeah
now i'm questioning how the how this
dude's purchased this house
now he looks like a young guy he seems
like a hard worker like a hustler
like me he's bought the house he hasn't
got any debt on it
which means he's bought it cash so i'm
wondering how he's paid for this house
i'm also wondering why he's not
refinancing this property because it
looks like it's in decent condition
he could refinance that take out 75
equity
and then and then put that into multiple
other properties hmos and become
financially independent i'm wondering
i'm wondering now what's happening i'm
interested but it's just basically you
just gotta
save save everything and keep your
expenses so low
don't obviously people call me are tight
or is cautious oh i'll never see you
spending money this that but you've got
to be tight
because then when you're older and you
get to that successful stage
then you can start helping the friends
and family out who have looked after you
but you have to be tight to start with
okay that's where i'd slightly disagree
with tyrone our friend right now
uh yeah listen of course there's times
when you do need to be tight with with
luxuries that you
haven't necessarily got right now this
this guy this guy is a grafter
you know he's he's clearly i don't know
how he saved up that money but i
even though he's only like 28 29 i can
tell that he's
made that money himself and he's
literally
saved it up and then bought this house
cash
i mean at least he's bought a hmo that's
hopefully going to be cash flow
flowing in positive but that is the very
slow way to do it
and he's talking about you know be
really tight because then one day
you can look after your family and your
friends and stuff i believe that
yeah when you work really hard and you
have serious discipline
and you delay your gratification for
ultimately one day when you can then
that works to a point but if you want to
in my opinion you want to get rich
and you want things to happen a bit
quicker you've got to be really smart
this guy works hard he's not he's not an
idiot he's smart
but i think he could be smarter with how
he leverages his money
and also how he gets his money in the
first place but
i don't know the guy i respect him
greatly but in order if he was
my mentee with his attitude i'd scale
things real big real quick i just i just
know it would
to be honest if i had three houses i'd
be
three houses fully paid i'd class myself
successful when you said if i had three
houses i was thinking you can do that
fast you can do that you know you say oh
you know what my end goal if i had three
houses i think you can do that in six
months and then you said fully paid
i'm thinking but why do you need the
houses to be fully paid because
the cash flow won't be much different
that house is fully paid
i don't know where that is but you
probably rent that out let's say that's
in in birmingham let's say
you'll probably rent that house out for
about fifteen hundred sixteen hundred
pound a month
and you're gonna have to pay bills
management you know a few hundred quid
here hundred quid there
without mortgage payments your cash flow
each month
might be around about 1200 pound a month
but with mortgage payments
let's say the house is 150 grand your
cash flow is going to be
maybe 850 900 pound a month just a
little bit less cash flow
but instead of you having to save up and
buy the house for
cash which is going to take years you
just
dude you need to leverage your money man
you really need to leverage your money
think cash flow rather than having to
own things outright but hey
thank god you've bought hmo thank god
you bought an investment instead of
buying a house to live in
but leverage leverage delivery that's my
lesson for you because then i don't have
to rely anything that replaces your
income
say for example you're only 2000 pounds
a month if you have three dwellings and
you're renting them out bringing that
same income in
anything that matches your income now
are classed as successful because you're
not actually
having to work for it as such if you get
a managing agent to come in and look
after the property
i totally agree with you tyrone that is
successful that's what i call
financially independent
because if you've got a recurring
passive property income
coming in that's covering your living
expenses
you're financially independent the thing
is you can get there pretty quick you
can get there in 12 months easy peasy
if you work smart as well as hard you
gotta you gotta keep up that crazy work
ethic
but also start working real smart as
well see for instance this video
my team found this video this video is
not available anywhere online
you should be publishing this video
building your brand right now
showing people what you've done and then
using the bank's money but also using
investors money
if you're using the bank's money and
investors money goodness forget three
hmos you got you go get 20 hmos you go
buy a castle
okay so you mentioned three properties
would be almost uh borderline successful
um you also said it's addictive so where
where where is it gonna stop where's the
line it is
it's a good question because it is very
addicting obviously
it's a good question it's very addicting
you get to three i probably will want
more but
no no you definitely will want more
never's enough because you know why
never's enough because when you've seen
that it's possible to then stop and say
i've got enough now
that's called selfish if you've got the
capacity and the skills and the brain
to make a lot of money but you don't
because you think i've got all i need
that's selfish because you can be
providing more accommodation for people
when you make money you're adding value
to lots of people investors
the economy tenants and then when you
make that money you're going to pay tax
on the money you're going to help the
economy that
way and then the money that you get
you're going to give some of it to
charity i hope
so you won't stop because you're not
selfish i will hopefully take a step
back and not have to work
70 80 hours a week and miss family
occasions family parties
i want to have a bit more family time so
that's my long-term goal okay so a bit
about you and how you got here then what
do you do on your days often
i have to laugh because i i'll get asked
that question so that's probably the the
biggest question i get asked what do you
do on your days off and to be honest i
very rarely have days off very rarely
and if i do have days off
i'm trying to read or study or speak to
knowledgeable people who can help me
achieve where i want to get to i'm not
just
doing pies i'm not doing all that i'm
not interested i just want to be
successful
i knew he was a grafter i knew it not
taking days off
and on top of that as well as being a
hard worker this guy's studying this
guy's researching
that's why he's got a hmo that's why he
managed to get the finance to buy the
html in the first place
don't ever call this boy look at him
look at it this is this is this is my
biggest risk
all my savings have literally invested
into this what's behind me
not knowing going in blind as a search
because i've i've not got any background
experience of this this is all new to me
i'm still learning
i've got the close friends around me
still trying to help and support me so
this is a big risk because i've got
literally everything's going into this
massive respect man and you know what
you want to be successful you have to
take a risk
every investment is a risk because
otherwise it wouldn't be called an
investment it'd be called a guarantee
nothing in life is guaranteed but when
you educate yourself work hard and
take massive action like you're doing
tyrone uh you're gonna be super
successful man i can't wait i'm gonna
see you one day on my youtube channel on
windows on a wednesday i know that
i've made a couple of regrets a couple
of mistakes with work i'd say sometimes
letting you
your pride get in in the way of where
you want to want to get to
nah nah nah you're not proud man that's
not your problem your problem is buying
something cash and then not refinancing
it and buying more houses
would you say that work has affected
your personal life uh works fit for my
personal life because i've missed a lot
of family occasions a lot of
weddings uh parties i've missed a lot of
things i should have went to
but i was in the process of just wanting
to get my goal i'm glad you didn't go to
those parties
you can be the guy who's at their
daughter's 16th birthday party but he's
broke
and is a failure to the family um and
ends up homeless shaking on the streets
because he's got no money but he was at
the family occasions or you can be the
guy that sacrifices it
takes the effort makes the money becomes
financially independent then once you're
financially
independent then you enjoy that your
family enjoy that and uh you needed to
miss those parties good for you
all my close friends are funny they know
me as a person and i speak to them all
the time you should save
don't listen to what other people have
to say because there's always people
saying ah you're being too tired are you
you don't spend your money
uh they'll they're going out clubbing
that don't interest me if you want to be
successful you've got to make sacrifices
and unfortunately i've had to make a lot
to get where i am today
okay so long-term goals then what's your
goals for five to ten years
let's say five to ten years i've won a
second property for sure i'd want a
second
probably well more than likely no way
outright but i will hopefully
be able to get a mortgage on the second
property have you got a plan to get
there with that have you got a plan
not yet literally i've just got to this
first this first hurdle and i've not got
to that stage yet but
i'm sure it will all unfold in the near
future second property in the next five
to ten years dude no
no no no no no you need a second
property the next three to six months
you're thinking way too small and i
think the reason you're thinking too
small is because in your mind
you've got to work to get the money to
then buy the house
but you don't have to do that and i
don't know what you're doing for a
living but
with your tenacity and and your skill
set that you've now got by having that
hmo
you can probably triple your what your
salaries as well i don't know what your
salary is but i bet you can triple it
i know you as a person already so if
you're trying to talk to me and sell me
something i know you as a person i know
you for the last few years what you've
been doing
and i'll go by your behavior not your
words see if you're saying oh yeah i
want to be successful how do you do that
how can you help me but then you're part
in every friday saturday night
and going to all these clubs i don't see
you as wanting to be successful because
i see you buying 150 pounds champagne
bottles in clubs trying to impress
people
that is so true there's so many talkers
it's almost when i started out in
property when i was 17
back in 2009 it wasn't cool to be an
entrepreneur
you know my friends were like what are
you doing it wasn't cool now
it's cool and everyone talks about it
like they're an entrepreneur
but really they're not because they just
want to be comfortable they want to be
at the club they want to be at home with
their mommy watching eastenders
losers bums so you know you got to
separate yourself from the talkers and
get around people that are actually the
walkers agree with you 100
i would say um i was addicted to being i
was addicted to working
as such um but now i've got this goal
hopefully i can step back a tiny bit
and i'm sure it will make me relax and
much more now i've got my first one
i wouldn't step back from work i would
just change the way you're working
i don't know what you're doing but this
is what i say about tripling your salary
you need
i would continue working and you better
stay addicted because if you're not
addicted then
that's bad that's bad news you've got
the fire in your belly that's good so
you've got to find a way how you can
make more money and then invest more
money
and leverage using banks money other
people's money that's that's what you
really need to get so here i've got four
bedrooms and i'm renting them out to
each student
so at the minute i've got four students
here um they've contracted here
out till july and um straight after this
i'm already looking now for the next
last students to come in
so you do make a lot more income having
individual rooms as opposed to
renting out to one family because
obviously you're getting
the whole income per room per person i i
recommend this more than a bottle a
hundred percent
because if we've got to let if you have
a family that live there and they move
out then you've got a void period that
you have to try and cover
and it's hard to cover it because there
will be a period where obviously they're
moving out they're moving in and
there'll be a gap whereas if you've got
four rooms
if one person doesn't move out or
something does happen i've still got
money income cash flow coming in one
thing tyrone does know about is he knows
about hmos
and i don't know where you learned about
hmos maybe you learned it from me i
don't know
maybe my youtube videos but you know a
lot about hmos and you're gonna you're
gonna be a great landlord and you're
gonna run this well
you deserve to make good money from it i
just wanna see you expand and grow and
do this more i've spoke to a couple of
businessmen and they won't touch
students they will not touch students
they'll touch working professionals
or things like that but for me there's
all these students in here
and obviously i know what students are
like working with students full-time so
i know what students are like
and i'm happy to take that risk and as
long as you make uh
build a good relationship with them as
such i know some landlords don't like to
as long as you build a good relationship
with them
i believe you can accomplish it and
everything will be safe tyron knows his
market
that's great you know what my hmos are
professional hmo house shares
they're professional they've got workers
in there he's going down the student
route because that's his market he knows
his market he understands his market
which is why this property is going to
do well the problem is when people
get greedy and they just take the first
person and move a student in and then a
tenant
who's a professional and then a dss and
it's like no
that's going to be a nightmare you need
to know your market know your product
and put the right people in you've gone
down the student route good for you i'd
like to say thank you for everyone who's
um
first of all watched my video and also
helped me along the way i've got a lot
of friends and family
who i'd know for sure wouldn't be here
today if it wasn't without wasn't
throughout them
um yeah i just appreciate that gratitude
one of the most important parts of being
an entrepreneur
can be a lonely road but when you when
you stay thankful to the people that
have helped you get there
really really important that's one of my
number one core values is gratitude
and honoring people that have helped me
get there so good good good props to you
man doing that me i'm still learning
myself so i'm still open to any ideas
you might have or
questions just feel free to get at me
second great trait is humility you know
so you've been thankful to those that
have helped you but now you're still
open-minded you say i'm still learning
dude i love that i think i'm going to be
a friend of yours one day i'm super
pumped to see that
i'm glad to see people winning i think
i've got your phone number as well we've
no i've never spoke to tyrone before
i've seen some of his comments on
youtube
one of my members of staff picked this
video up he sent it direct
um i think i've got his number somewhere
i've never spoken to tyrone ever
let me see because i'm gonna i'm gonna
phone it phone him and i'm gonna thank
him for
making this video and i'm going to
congratulate him on his success and i'm
going to encourage him to become more
successful
tyrone saxton what's happening oh wow
how you doing my friend
i just thought i just thought i'd give
you i just thought i'd give you a shout
out bro just to say
a couple things a couple things firstly
uh
thanks for thank just thanks for your
thanks for your support and stuff on the
youtube channel i appreciate your
comments but
secondly i watched your uh i watched
your video bro and honestly it was sick
dude your video is good man honestly
respect you're one of the
you're one of the the hardest working
grafters i've seen bro
so what i want to know a couple things i
want to know firstly when you're going
to be on uh
winners on a wednesday and secondly
when you're going to refinance that
house and start getting some debt
because i noticed that you you're not
you're not
you're not a uh a fan of debt but i
think that
i think you could change that
yo can you hear me sorry carry on
i was just saying a couple of things
firstly is when you're going to be on
winners wednesday secondly when are you
going to refinance your hmo and start
building that empire
when are you going to refinance your hmo
and get some uh
and get some more houses
yes that's good man that's good because
i've noticed in some of your comments
you seem to have a little bit of a
um i don't know if it's like a a
a mindset blockage around around debt
yeah yeah i i've always hated debt if i
can't buy someone i just i just don't
like that
i love just only purchasing something if
i've got it it's just everyone's
different and i've just
i've always felt uncomfortable owing so
much money yeah think your video
yeah i mean you understand the
difference between
debt that serves you and debt that
doesn't know right
yeah yeah my life isn't that watching
your videos about live videos
yeah yeah exactly exactly um but no
that's that's
[ __ ] listen your videos your video is
amazing
you should be sharing it and uh honestly
as i say appreciate the
the support and stuff let me know once
you've got a couple one or two more hmos
once you've kind of got around the 2 000
a month mark coming in
from property let's uh let's hook up and
do an interview
definitely
you're so welcome tyrone god bless keep
doing what you're doing my friend
there we go tyrone freaking phenomenal
to speak to you bro
thank you so much for picking up my call
i'm glad you did and i look forward to
seeing you on winners on the wednesday
when you got a couple more houses
peace out thanks for watching this folks
if you enjoy my videos
smash the like button subscribe turn the
notification bell on you never know when
you might just feature on my channel
you never know when i might just
suddenly pick up the phone and phone you
just to congratulate your success i love
i love congratulating people's successes
and i love holding people account to
their goals
and of course teaching people and
equipping people about property
investing and financial freedom so
subscribe
turn the notification bell on and i'll
see you next time
you